a culture that you know is not going to identify with you simply as you are
that are saying they're not gonna code switch for the benefit of their employer
decide if you want to engage in identity politics or not
unless you go above and beyond to identify with the culture that is not your own
and if you're the minority that becomes really hard to do
given what we already know about office politics
I'm curious what you guys think about this
let me know in the comments below
it's true you have to at some point
but on the other hand being authentically yourself has its rewards as well
or unprofessional
it's a matter of extreme assimilation to
and I think identity politics goes far beyond just being professional
there's a lot of people within this generation
to achieve the level of success that you're looking for
they wanna promote people that remind them of themselves
people simply *gravitate* towards what they're most familiar with
I really love that she made a video about this
because if you're black in corporate America or a person of color